The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Well,
in the last lecture
we introduced the z transform.
In this lecture, I'd
like to go backwards.
That is, I'd like to introduce
the inverse z transform
and demonstrate some of its
properties with a few examples.
To begin with, let me remind you
of the z transform relationship
as we talked about it
in the last lecture.
The z transform X of
z of a sequence x of n
is given by the sum of x of
n times z to the minus n.
The inverse z
transform, of course,
is the relationship,
or the set of rules,
that allow us to obtain x
of n the original sequence
from its z transform, x of z.
There are a variety
of methods that
can be used for implementing
the inverse z transform.
Some of them are somewhat
informal methods.
And others, one in particular
which we'll talk about,
is a somewhat formal method.
To begin with, an
informal method
and a method that,
in fact, most of us
tend to use the most
often is a method
that we could refer to as the
inspection method for computing
the inverse z transform.
Basically, the
inspection method says
if we've computed a z
transform from a sequence,
then by looking at
that z transform,
we can recognize more or less
by inspection the sequence
that that z transform came from.
For example, we have
worked several times now
the computation
of the z transform
of an exponential
sequence, which
is a right sided sequence,
and gotten is the answer,
or the z transform, 1 over 1
minus a z to the minus one,
with a region of convergence
for the magnitude of z greater
than the magnitude of a.
Consequently, having
worked that example,
if I now present you with
this z transform and ask you
what sequence generated it.
One way of doing that,
obviously, is by inspection.
By recognizing that
this sequence generates
that z transform.
Another example that
we've worked several times
now is the exponential
sequence, which is left sided.
That is 0 for n
greater than zero,
generating the same
ratio of polynomials
as in the right
sided exponential,
but with a region
of convergence which
is the interior of
a circle rather than
in this case where the
region of convergence
is the exterior of a circle.
And in fact, it was the
comparison between these two z
transforms that
caused us to focus
in the last lecture
on the importance
of the region of convergence.
So this is one method, which
I emphasize again is in fact,
one of the most common methods.
That is, just simply recognizing
the z transform as something
that we've computed
previously from a sequence.
And that obviously also
as you work more examples,
you build up a larger list
of sequences and z transforms
which pairs what
you can recognize.
The second method for computing
the inverse z transform
is based on the fact that the
z transform relationship is
basically a power series in z.
That is, if we look back here
at the z transform expression,
this is essentially a power
series relationship which
expands x of z in powers of z.
Consequently, given
a z transform,
if we can expand it in
terms of powers of z,
then we can pick off the
coefficients in that expansion
as values of the
sequence x of n.
For example, let's
take the sequence,
sorry the z transform x of z,
which is 1 over 1 minus a z
to the minus 1.
Or we can rewrite it
as z over z minus a.
Now this of course
is a z transform
whose inverse we know how
to compute by inspection.
However, we can also
compute the inverse z
transform by expanding this
expression in a power series.
Let's divide 1 by 1
minus a z to the minus 1,
and then recognize
the coefficients
in that expansion as values
of the sequence X of n.
So carrying that out.
We have 1 divided into 1 is 1.
Multiplying back we have 1
minus a z to the minus 1.
Subtracting we then
have a z to the minus 1.
Dividing by 1 we then have
a times z to the minus 1.
Multiplying down again,
we have a z to the minus 1
minus a squared
z to the minus 2.
Subtracting we have a
squared z to the minus 2.
Dividing by 1 we have a
And if we continue this, we'll
generate terms 1, a times
z to the minus 1, a squared
times z to the minus 2,
a cubed times z to the
minus 3, et cetera.
This series will continue with
an infinite number of terms.
And we can recognize then this
as the expansion of x of z
in the form the sum of x
n times z to the minus n.
Consequently, we can recognize
that apparently x of n
is 1 at n equal zero, a at
n equals 1, a squared at n
equals 2, a cubed
at n equals 3, etc.
Of course, there
are lots of ways
of expanding a function
like this in a power series.
For example, if I simply reverse
the order of these two terms
and carried out the division,
this isn't the series I'd get.
What I'd get instead is the
series, which is minus a
to the minus 1 times z,
minus a to the minus 2 times
z squared, minus a to the
minus 3 times z cubed, etc.
In that case, if this
was the expansion,
then what I would have to
recognize as the sequence
corresponding to this is
the sequence which is 0 at n
equals zero.
It has no terms of the form z
to the minus a positive power.
So apparently, it's all 0
for n greater than zero.
And it's minus a to the minus
1 at n equals minus 1, minus a
to the minus 2 at n
equals minus 2, etc.
So in fact, for this example,
I could expand this either
in this power series, or I could
expand it in this power series.
Well, which power series
is the right power series?
We know in fact that given
just this ratio of polynomials,
there are several choices
for the sequence that it
corresponds to depending on
the region of convergence.
If I associate as the
region of convergence
the magnitude of z greater
than the magnitude of a,
then it's this power
series that converges.
And this power series diverges.
So for that region
of convergence,
that is with the
magnitude of z greater
than the magnitude of a as
the region of convergence,
this is the power series.
And consequently, the
answer is a to the n times
u of n, which of course
is consistent with what
we know already or equivalently
consistent with the inspection
method.
On the other hand, if
the region of convergence
was the magnitude of z less
than the magnitude of a,
then it's this power
series that converges.
And consequently
in that case, we
get a left sided sequence, which
again is consistent with what
we know either from
the inspection method
or equivalently
from the examples
that we've worked before.
One obvious drawback
to the power series
is the fact that
when we generate
the inverse z
transform this way,
we get the values in the
sequence as individual terms.
That is, we generate x
of n not in closed form.
We generate it as a sequence.
For simple sequences
of course, we
can recognize a closed
form form for that.
But in more complicated
cases, we can't.
All right.
A third method for
generating the inverse z
transform is
basically an extension
of the inspection
method, which allows
us to take a more complicated z
transform expression and expand
it out in terms of terms that
we can recognize by inspection.
And this method I'll
refer to as the method
based on the partial
fraction expansion.
I assume that some
of you are familiar
with the partial fraction
expansion in general
for a rational function.
But in case you're not or
in case you're rusty on it,
let me just quickly review
what the partial fraction
expansion consists of.
Let's consider the general
function of a variable,
I'll take as a complex
variable x, which
is a rational function in x.
It is one polynomial in
the numerator divided
by a denominator polynomial.
And let me remark incidentally
that you shouldn't confuse
this x with the
sequence values x of n
that we've been referring to.
This is simply some
arbitrary complex number,
or complex variable.
Now I can in general expand
the rational function
in terms of an expansion
of a form which,
at least under certain
simple conditions,
is a sum of terms of
the form of a constant,
Rk divided by x minus
xk, where the x minus xk
are the roots of the
denominator polynomial q of x.
And these coefficients are
referred to as the residues.
Now to expand this rational
function in this form
without additional terms, I need
to apply the restriction, which
I'll do for the purposes
of this lecture,
that the order of the
numerator polynomial
is less than the order of
the denominator polynomial,
and that in addition,
there are no multiple order
roots of the
denominator polynomial.
In other words, the denominator
polynomial is n-th order,
then the n roots of the
denominator polynomial
are distinct.
In the text, there is the
more general discussion
of the partial
fraction expansion
when the order of
the numerator is
greater than or equal to
the order of the denominator
or if there are
multiple order roots.
The essential ideas of
course don't change.
It's just the mechanics of
implementing the expansion
in the form of the expansion.
So for this lecture we'll
assume that the expansion simply
has terms of this form.
And this then is referred
to as the partial fraction
expansion of f of x.
Now how do we get
the coefficients Rk
in the expansion?
Well essentially by
recognizing that if we
multiply f of x by one of
the denominator factors,
say x minus xr, and evaluate
that product of x equals xr.
Then relating that
to this sum, as I've
indicated here, when
k is equal to r,
these two factors cancel out.
When k is not equal
to r, then when
I substitute x equals xr in
here, then this term vanishes.
So basically then, what
happens inside this sum is
that the term inside
this sum is equal to 0
for k not equal to r, and
it's equal to capital Rr, that
is the residue at the pole, x
equals xr when k is equal to r.
So consequently,
there's only one term
left in this sum,
which is capital Rr.
And therefore the residues,
that is capital Rr,
can be obtained by multiplying
f of x by x minus xr,
evaluating the result
at x equals xr.
And the resulting
number is the residue
of f of x at the
pole x equals xr.
That's for the case
of simple order
poles, that is first order roots
of the denominator polynomial.
And also for the case when
the order of the numerator
polynomial is less than or equal
to the order of the denominator
polynomial.
And just store away for later,
because I want to refer back
to this point,
that in particular,
when there are
multiple order poles,
the evaluation of the residue
is somewhat more complicated.
In particular it
involves computing
some derivatives, et cetera.
And the more the higher the
multiplicity of the pole,
the more complicated it is.
And that's a point that
will sneak back at us
toward the end of the lecture.
Now this of course is for a
general rational function.
Let's apply this now to
the inverse z transform.
Well, we know that
the z transform--
well let's restrict
ourselves to the case
where the z transform is
a rational function of z
or z to the minus 1.
And consequently we
can, referring back
to the general notion of the
partial fraction expansion,
either think of the
variable z as what
we're calling x over
there, in which case
we have an expansion of
the z transform in the form
of the sum on k of ak
divided by z minus little ak,
where the little ak's are
the poles, and the capital
Ak's are the residues.
Alternatively, if we interpret
z to the minus 1 as x, then
we can expand x of z in the
form of some other residues
Bk divided by z to the minus 1
minus some coefficient, little
bk.
Or we can rewrite that
as capital Bk divided
by 1 minus ak z to the minus 1.
So here we're
expanding in terms of--
we're treating the z transform
as a rational function in z.
Here we're treating
the z transform
as a rational function
in z to the minus 1.
So what does the
method consist of?
Well the method consists
of expanding x of z
in terms of simple
terms like this,
and then using the
inspection method
to recognize what the
inverse transform is for each
of the individual terms.
To get the final sequence
then, we add those up.
That is, we've expressed
the z transform
as a sum of simple factors.
So the sequence, the
original sequence,
we can express as the
sum of the inverse z
transform obtained by the
expect inspection method
of each of the
individual factors.
All right.
Let's just work a simple
example to show you
what the mechanics are of
this and how it works out.
Let's take an example where
x of z is 1 over 1 minus 1/2
z to the minus 1 times 1
minus 1/4 z to the minus 1
with a region of
convergence which
I'll take as the magnitude
of z greater than a half.
This has two poles of course.
One at z equals 1/2, the
other at z equals 1/4.
And the region of convergence
is outside the outermost pole.
So what we expect to get
is a right sided sequence.
And let's work this
one by treating
the variable x in our previous
discussion as z to the minus 1.
And obviously, it doesn't
matter which one we use.
Although it turns out
actually that depending
on how you pick it,
you either end up
with a numerator
polynomial whose order
is greater than the denominator
polynomial, or the other way
around.
OK.
Well, so we want then to
expand this z transform
in terms of a sum of factors.
And let's just rewrite
this to make things
a little clearer by multiplying
denominator and numerator by 2,
by minus 2 rather, and
then also by minus 4.
We can simply rewrite this as 8
divided by z to minus 1 minus 2
times z to the minus 1 minus 4.
So that it's more in the form
of x minus a constant times
x minus another constant.
All right.
Well, so here then we
have the z transform
that we want to expand
in a partial fraction
expansion in terms of
treating z to the minus 1
as the complex variable
x in the expansion.
We have two poles, two roots
of the denominator polynomial,
one at z to the minus
1 equals 2, the other
at z the minus 1 equals 4.
So we need to
calculate the residues
at each of those roots.
To calculate the residue at
z to the minus 1 equals 2,
what are the steps?
Well, we multiply this by
z to the minus 1 minus 2.
That is, x minus 2 where
x we're interpreting as z
to the minus 1.
And then evaluate the result
at z to the minus 1 equals 2.
Well obviously of course, this
term cancels out that term.
And we want to do that before
we substitute z to the minus 1
equals 2.
And then substituting
z to the minus 1
equals 2, we get minus 2 left
over in the denominator divided
into eight.
And that's equal to minus 4.
So the residue then
at z to the minus 1
equals 2 is equal to minus 4.
Similarly, to calculate
the residue at the root
z to the minus 1 equals
4, we multiply by z
to the minus 1 minus 4.
Then these two terms
will cancel out.
Evaluate the resulting
expression at z to the minus 1
equals 4.
So we have 4 minus 2
is 2 and to 8 is 4.
And the residue then at z
to the minus 1 equals 4,
the residue is equal to 4.
Consequently, the partial
fraction expansion for x of z,
for this x of z, is
minus 4, minus 4, over z
to the minus 1 minus 2 plus 4
over z to the minus 1 minus 4.
Well finally, let's
just put this back
in a form that is more the
form that we're used to looking
at the z transform in.
In particular multiplying
this piece, numerator
and denominator, by minus 1/2,
we get 2 over 1 minus 1/2 z
to the minus 1.
Here, multiplying numerator
and denominator by minus 1/4,
we get minus 1 over 1
minus 1/4 z to the minus 1.
And now we've broken x of z
into a form that allows us
to use the inspection method.
That is, we can
recognize from this--
remember that the
region of convergence
was outside a circle.
So we want to interpret
the region of convergence
to be the same here.
So consequently for this piece
we end up with 2 times 1/2
to the n times u of n.
That's an n.
And for this piece we end up
with minus 1 times a quarter
to the n times u of n.
So by breaking x of z into a
sum of components, simple terms,
we were then able to apply
the inspection method
to each one of those to get
the resulting z transform
in a closed form expression,
or at least the sum
of some closed form expression.
All right.
So that then is
basically an extension
of the inspection method.
When the inspection method
by itself doesn't work,
it's usually the partial
fraction expansion method
that one uses, perhaps
also in conjunction
with some properties of
the z transform, which
is something that will be going
into more in the next lecture.
Now finally, there is a
somewhat more formal way
of evaluating the
inverse z transform.
And in some cases, it's
important to actually use
this to explicitly evaluate
the inverse z transform.
In other cases, it's important
to make reference to the more
formal inverse
transform relationship
to discuss properties of
the inverse z transform.
So sometimes the formal
inverse transform
is computationally useful.
In other cases, it's
useful in proving
theorems or
developing properties
or something of the sort.
Well this method, the
final method and the most
formal method, is the
method that I refer to here
as contour integration.
And let me basically
hand it to you.
That is, rather than go
through a derivation,
let me just simply state
what the inverse z transform
relationship is.
In the text there is
a derivation of this.
And so for the purposes
of the lecture itself,
let me just presented.
Any objections?
No.
So and then also work through
at least one example to show you
what the mechanics are.
It's another nice thing
about videotape lectures,
there are never any objection.
OK.
Well, here it is.
This is the inverse z transform.
What does it say?
It says the sequence x of n is
1 over 2 pi j times a contour
integral, which I'll return to
in a second, of x of z times
z to the n minus 1 dz.
If you're not used to looking
at an inverse transform
relationship like
this, let me just
indicate that it's
surprising how easy it
is to verify that, in
fact, this is the inverse z
transform relationship,
basically using the Cauchy
residue theorem.
But this is it.
This is, of course,
a complex function.
This is a complex integral.
And the important
thing to straighten out
is this contour c.
The contours c is a closed
contour in the z plane
which encircles the origin.
So it's a closed contour.
It encircles the origin.
It's like a circle that
goes around the origin,
with another very
important condition on it.
Which is that it lies inside
the region of convergence
of x of z.
Well, that's not surprising,
because the region
of convergence for x of z is the
only place where we're allowed
to stick in values for z.
So obviously quote,
we're not allowed
to look at values of this
integrand except where x of z
makes sense, that is except
in the region of convergence.
So obviously then, we have
to evaluate this integral
considering only values
of z inside the region
of convergence.
So contour c is a closed
contour in the z plane,
encircles the origin, and
it lies inside the region
of convergence.
Now for x of z, a
rational function of z,
which are the cases
we've been talking about,
this entire integrand
is a rational function.
And consequently, a contour
integral of this type
can be simply evaluated
using the notion of residues.
I'll state, and hopefully
this is a property
of complex contour integrals
that you're familiar with,
that the integral of a
rational function of that type,
the integral itself is 2 pi j
times the sum of the residues
inside the contour.
And that 2 pi j cancels
out as 1 over 2 pi j.
And consequently,
x of n is simply
the sum of the residues of x
of z times z to the n minus 1
at the poles inside
the contour c.
The poles of what?
The poles not of x and
z only, but the poles
of the entire integrand.
That is, x of z multiplied
by z to the n minus 1.
Important point, which it's
important to keep in mind.
The integral or the residues
that we're looking at
are the residues, not
just of x of z, but x of z
multiplied by z
to the n minus 1.
Another statement,
just tuck it away,
is that this is valid for
both n greater than zero
and equal to zero
and n less than 0.
We'll see in a minute that
for n greater than zero,
it might be easier to evaluate
than for n less than 0,
depending on the example.
But tuck away the fact
that this expression is
a valid expression,
no matter whether n
is positive or negative
or of course zero.
All right.
Let's look at the mechanics
of evaluating the inverse z
transform this way.
Let's return to the example x
of z equals 1 over 1 minus 1/2 z
to the minus 1 with a
region of convergence
the magnitude of z
greater than 1/2.
And by the way,
by now if there's
one thing you should have
gotten out of these lectures,
it certainly should be
to be able to recognize
what the inverse z
transform of this is.
It's an example that I guess we
bounced around so many times.
All right.
Let's look at this z transform.
First, let's just look
at x of z in the z plane.
Here's the z plane.
We have a pole at z equals 1/2.
And we have a 0
at z equals zero.
Here's the unit circle.
And in green, what
I've indicated
is the region of convergence.
Now to do the
contour integration,
it's not just x of z
that we're looking at.
It's x of z times z to
the n minus 1 equals
z to the n over z minus 1/2.
Incidentally, what
is the contour
of integration look like then
the z plane for this example?
It's a closed contour inside
the region of convergence
and encircling the origin.
So for example, it's a
contour that looks like this.
And incidentally,
it is and I don't
think I stress this before, it's
a counter-clockwise contour.
So this is the contour c.
It's a counterclockwise contour.
As I've drawn it, I didn't
draw a very good circle,
partly because I can't.
But in fact, it also
emphasizes the fact
that it doesn't
have to be a circle.
It just has to be closed, inside
the region of convergence,
and circling the origin.
And a counterclockwise contour.
All right.
How many poles of x of z times
z to the n minus 1 are there?
That is, how many
places are there
that we have to
evaluate residues?
Well let's look,
first of all, at n
greater than or equal to 0.
This doesn't
introduce any poles.
This introduces one
pole equals 1/2.
So we only need to evaluate
the residue of this at this one
pole that is at z equals 1/2.
So we want to compute the
residue then of x of z times
z to the n minus
1 at z equals 1/2.
So that z to the
n over z minus 1/2
multiplied by z minus 1/2
evaluated and z equals 1/2.
These two cancel out.
And we end up with
simply 1/2 to the n.
So for n greater than or equal
to 0, the sequence x of n
is just a half to the n.
So that's part of
the result. Now we
have to get the inverse z
transform for n less than zero.
Well for n less than 0, again
of course we have 1 pole
and z equal to 1/2.
But now, remember that
we had this factor, which
was z to the n.
And for n negative that
introduces poles at the origin.
And in fact it,
introduces n poles.
So for n less than 0, we
have not only this pole,
but we have n poles
at z equals 0.
That's a problem.
Because now we're going to
have to evaluate the residues
and each of these poles.
And the more negative value of n
we're trying to get x of n for,
the worse it gets, because
the higher the multiplicity
of the pole.
All right.
But look, we've seen
this example before.
We know that x of n
is 1/2 to the n for n
greater than or equal to 0
and it's 0 for n less than 0.
As we knew that from other times
that we've worked this example.
So obviously, there
must be some easy way
to get the fact that x of
n, in fact for this example,
is 0 for n less than 0.
All right.
Let's take a look at
a way, an easy way.
Here we have, again, the
inverse z transform. x of n
is 1 over 2 pi j times
this contour integral.
And let's simply make a
substitution of variables.
Let's make the
substitution of variables z
equal to p to the minus 1, in
which case z to the n minus 1
is equal to p to
the minus n plus 1.
Which means incidentally
that with z equal to r e
to of the j theta, p, this new
variable, is 1 over r times
e to the minus j theta.
So now we want to make the
substitution of variables
in this contour integral.
Well, let's see-- dz is
minus p to the minus 2,
just differentiating this.
Well, I'll let you go through
the algebra on your own.
But if you take this
substitution of variables,
stuff it into that contour
integral, then the result
that we end up with is that
x of n is equal to minus 1
over 2 pi j, the minus
coming from the fact
that dz is minus p to
the minus 2 times dp.
That's that minus sign.
x of 1 over p times p to
the minus n minus 1 dp.
And what happens to the contour?
Well the contour previously was,
let's say r e to the j theta.
Let's take it as a
circular contour.
So the contour now is 1 over
r e to the minus j theta.
That means as one
consequence that
our old
counter-clockwise contour
turns into a clockwise contour.
So that's what I've
indicated here.
But we also have
this minus sign.
And we can use that
minus sign to change
the direction of the contour.
So if we change the contour back
to a counterclockwise contour,
get rid of the minus sign.
Then finally we have
the expression x of n
is 1 over 2 pi j times the
contour integral of capital X
of 1 over p p to the
minus n minus 1 dp.
And what is this contour now?
Well if the old contour C was
circular with a radius of r,
this contour c prime is a circle
with a radius of 1 over r.
Well let's just look at what
this substitution of variable z
to 1 over p did as
a matter of fact.
Here I've illustrated
the z plane.
the p plane.
The unit circle in the z plane,
when I replace z by 1 over p,
turns again into the unit
circle in the p plane,
because the unit circle is
where the magnitude of z is 1.
And if I take the reciprocal of
that, the magnitude is still 1.
The important thing is what
happened to this contour.
Well this contour got converted
if it was outside the unit
circle into a new contour which
is inside the unit circle.
And in fact, in general,
stuff that was in here,
the inside of the
unit circle, is
going to end up outside the
unit circle in the p plane.
And things that were outside
the unit circle in the z plane
are going to end up inside the
unit circle in the p plane.
This transformation simply takes
stuff outside the unit circle
and folds it inside
the unit circle,
takes things inside
the unit circle
and folds them outside
the unit circle.
And it's just simply a
substitution of variables.
All right.
Now with this
substitution of variables,
let's return to the example
that we've been working.
We have our example.
x of z is 1 over 1 minus
1/2 z to the minus 1,
the magnitude of z
greater than 1/2.
We want to replace
z by 1 over p.
So we want x of 1 over p.
x of 1 over p, then simply
replacing z to the minus 1
by p, is 1 over 1
minus 1/2 times p.
If this was true
for the magnitude
of z greater than
1/2, then this is
true for the magnitude
of p less than 1/2.
So we get minus 2
divided by p minus 2.
If we look at this
in the p plane,
we have then a pole
in the p plane.
The pole in the z plane
was at z equals 1/2.
So the pole in the p
plane is at p equals 2.
That's now outside
the unit circle.
The region of convergence,
now, is inside
the circle of radius 2.
And where is the contour
of integration c prime?
Well that now is inside
the circle of radius 2.
For example, let's draw it here.
So this is now the
contour c prime.
All right.
We want finally to evaluate
the inverse z transform,
or the inverse p
transform, by looking
at the residues of x of 1 over p
times p to the minus n minus 1.
The residues of that at
its roots, at its poles,
that are inside the contour
of integration c prime.
Well, for n less than 0, we
have one pole at p equals 2.
And for n negative, this
will contribute no poles.
Therefore, there are no roots
of this inside this contour.
And consequently, the contour
integral is obviously zero.
So x of n is equal to
zero for n less than 0.
Now for greater
than or equal to 0,
we have one pole at p equals 2.
But then because of this factor,
p to the minus n minus 1,
we have n plus 1
poles at p equals 0.
So now it seems like for n
greater than or equal to 0,
we're back where
we started from.
Because now we have these
multiple order poles at p
equals 0.
What do we do about that?
Well, we don't have to
do anything about it.
Because we already considered
the case for n greater than
or equal to 0.
In that case, we didn't run
into multiple order poles
at the origin.
We used the substitution
of variables,
z equals 1 over p to
basically avoid that problem
and to get the answer
for n less than 0.
So consequently, the
answer that we get,
which we finally know to be
the right answer in fact,
is that x of n is equal
to 0 for n less than zero.
And as we worked out before,
x of n is equal to 1/2
to the n for n greater
than or equal to 0.
Or finally, x of n is equal
to 1/2 to the n times u of n.
All right.
That's an example we've
worked out now three times.
And three times we got the same
answer, so it must be right.
All right.
Well this roughs
out the inverse z
transform, several methods
for getting the inverse z
transform.
Obviously, to become fluent
with the inverse z transform
requires working
a lot of examples.
And you know where
you going to have
all those examples to work.
That is, in the study guide.
And you'll find as I
stressed previously,
that as you work more and
more examples, what you find
in computing
inverse z transforms
is that more and
more frequently,
you're able to
recognize the answer.
Well, in the next lecture,
we'll complete the discussion
of the z transform.
In particular, we'll
among other things
present some properties
of the z transform, which
also by the way, help us in
computing inverse z transforms.
And so in the next
lecture, we'll
be continuing the topic
of the z transform,
and in fact
concluding the topic.
Thank you.